here in the valley booster shots started
going into arms today many people made
their way to pharmacies and vaccine
clinics madison kimbrough joins us live
from the health district a location for
these coveted vaccines madison
yeah i spoke to a lot of people that
said getting this booster ahead of the
holiday is the extra protection and
confidence they need in order to feel
safe
a year ago we were warned not to spend
the holidays with family and friends as
covet cases were soaring and now this
year holiday cheer especially with the
announcement of boosters for adults i'm
thrilled that it is available for
everybody because i think there was a
lot of confusion about who qualified and
who didn't alexia vernon was recently
diagnosed with thyroid cancer but is now
in remission her mother was also
diagnosed and that's why she says the
booster is vital for her family to enjoy
the holidays
we are a family that wears our masks at
all times and even still if you want to
eat you need to take a mask off the
weather has just cooled down we're going
to be eating inside and it feels like
the responsible thing to do for her and
really for all of us as soon as wylanda
bernstein heard the news she rolled up
her sleeve with hopes that the holiday
will be better than in 2020 i'm fully
vaccinated and just want to continue to
stay protected as best as possible for
myself
family friends
if you do plan to get boosted this
weekend it's recommended to make an
appointment but there are places you can
go in to just walk in and get your
booster shot right then and right there
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now